hi welcome to Google developers live my
name is Maru and with me today I have
used
fatale affirm or deeds today we have a
very exciting show we're going to go
over the Orbitz integration with the
wallet objects API this is the second
show we're doing to showcase the Orbitz
integration with Google Wallet the
wallet objects API is a simple platform
that allows developers to build digital
versions of physical cards that can be
stored in Google Wallet such as loyalty
cards boarding passes offers and more it
also allows you to engage your customers
through real-time updates location-based
notifications and messaging if you watch
last week's GDL you see how Orbitz
integrated with the instant buy API to
speed up checkout if you haven't watched
that video go ahead and watch it after
this one today yourself is gonna walk us
through their integration with the
wallet objects API and go over some
integration questions and do a demo of
how it works with India how you said how
are you thanks for joining us thanks for
having me we're so glad to have you here
why don't we go over some questions
first and then let's do a demo of how
the the account sign up and the linking
works from within our app why don't you
tell us a little bit of how why big
Orbitz decide to integrate the Orbitz
rewards program into Google Wallet sure
so the idea was to reach the large user
base of the Google Wallet app in order
to drive awareness of the Orbitz reward
loyalty program that we just launched
nessip Tober and this would also
increase memberships on our website so
now that you guys are done with the
integration how easy or difficult was it
to do to integrate with a wallet objects
API oh great question so you know
working with the grid was a new API
always comes with its own set of
challenges but also comes with a great
learning experience so while some parts
of the documentation were very well
described and the steps are very easy to
follow some other parts were evolving as
we are working on that feature I do have
to mention though that we did get a
great support from our Google contact
aka Maru thanks for that and that
definitely helped speeding up the
process and make it as much as possible
it was also fun working with you guys
so if I book Hotel on orbit when do I
get my or box updated in the app do I
get them updated at the same day or the
next day can you tell us a little bit
about that process on update yeah so as
of now it takes 24 hours for the Orbitz
balance to be updated and the way we do
that is that we run a daily job that
checks the status of our loyalty members
who registered or linked through the
Google Wallet app and we get the most
recent version of the loyalty object
compare that to our local database if
there's any differences in there or
bucks balance or their status then we
have to push a change to this object
through the API calls in the
documentation this way next time the
user opened the app they would see their
updated balance so let's take a look at
a demo and how I can book a hotel on
Orbitz and earn some air box sure let me
show you how so here we go we go to the
hotels path let's look for a city let's
say Las Vegas somewhere warmer than here
because it's pretty cold in Chicago now
and speak a dates sometime in April
search
all right so now I get a list of hotels
looks like there's some deals look for
good one and yeah that seems like a good
deal
it's my budget let's check the pictures
all right looks good to me
convinced so let the room take that one
and now you can see the summary I see
that mobile steel is applied and see
this form I don't want to really fill
all this information so now that we
integrated the Google+ sign-in so what I
can do is I can click sign in professor
booking Google+ take a Google account
and boom now I'm signed in to Orbitz
through Google+ and since I'm a loyalty
member you can see here that I can earn
a dollar and 89 cents in or bucks if I
made this booking and also because I'm
signed in through Google+ if I clicked
on by with Google Wallet
I'll find the credit card in fine I
don't need to add any more information
just click continue display the credit
card check the information confirm
everything is right and now if
everything went fine we'll see the
confirmation screen with the record
locator for this booking and also tell
you how many or bucks you earned on this
booking boom that's how easy it is wow
that was pretty easy and quick I really
like the new Google+ integration that
you guys did so now that I earned some
air box let's take a look at how we can
link our existing Orbitz rewards account
into Google Wallet and then take a look
at my points that we just earned sure
let me show you so here we have the
Google Wallet app you're gonna go to
loyalty programs and a program
and look for orbits here you go and see
here that's the orbits reward
description I'll get up to five percent
on hotels on our mobile apps plus one
percent and since I'm already a member
I'm gonna click on a member with my
email that's the same email that I use
to sign in on Orbitz write the program
now there's a verify first and last name
and my phone number you can verify and
here you go so now we see the or box and
if you click on this card you'll get the
loyalty object that we talked about
earlier and then you see the updated
balance great that's it it can't get any
easier than that so you open the app and
you look for the program where we three
words then you just enter the same email
address that we used to create or Orbitz
rewards account online and then you can
check your points right yeah so the
Google Wallet app also allows users to
sign up for a new loyalty program in
case they haven't signed up already or
of course link to an existing account
away that you just saw on the demo
Google will post a JSON request with the
user provided information to the
merchants web service URL and then the
merchants web service needs to respond
back to Google with either a success or
failure and in the case of a success
then you need to send back the loyalty
object that will save on that user which
is in this case the loyalty card Yousef
thanks so much for joining us it was
great to have you thanks for inviting me
I really learned a lot from working on
this project and be sure to check out
the Orbitz loyalty program Orbitz
rewards in Google Wallet and join now to
start earning some more bucks or link
your existing account if you already
have one to keep track of your box as
well for more videos
on wallet objects please go to
developers.google.com slash live slash
wallet or you can also find us at
Google+ Plus Google Wallet and thanks
for joining us for another week of
Google developers live see you next time
you